bonjour je suis razon alandry j'ai 22
ans et je viens d'obtenir mon bts banque
je n'ai pas de permis je n'ai pas de
véhicule et j'habite sur sainte clotilde
je recherche un contrat de
professionnalisation dans le secteur
commercial
donc dans le cadre de ma licence
professionnelle donc dans le cadre de
cette formation je souhaiterait intégrer
une entreprise dans le dans la région
nord
donc je recherche un une entreprise qui
veut bien m'accueillir donc dans le
cadre de ma licence professionnelle pour
signer un contrat de
professionnalisation plus précisément
l'entreprise
du secteur commercial j'ai obtenu un bac
sciences et technologies de la gestion
en 2009 et je viens d'obtenir mon bts
banque donc au lycée le verger de sainte
marie je suis motivé dynamique et
rigoureux organisé dans mon travail je
suis à l'écouté des autres j'aime le
travail en équipe
j'aime aller au cinéma je fais du sport
je suis le capitaine d'une équipe de
foot sur saint denis
j'aime également la photographie tout ce
qui est en tueur je suis dynamique et
motivée donc n'hésitez pas à me
contacter